- The Try Guys have tried
a lot of medical stuff.
(Keith screaming)
Let's see what's been legit
and what's been not.
Peewoop!
(playful music)
The Try Guys.
The Try Guys, guys, try prostate exams?
- [Producer] The Try Guys:
Guys Try Prostate Exams.
- Ah.
- Movember is this thing
that helps raise money
and awareness for prostate cancer.
- Movember's a great organization.
We're not growing mustaches.
We're doing one better.
- And it involves the finger.
- Butt stuff!
- Today, we are gonna get
our prostates examined.
- At least they said finger.
I remember watching the first episode
of "Grey's Anatomy".
- I'm just gonna insert my fingers
into your rectum.
- Why fingers?
- If it takes just one finger up the butt
to find out a life or death situation,
stick the whole hand up my butt.
- Wait, what did he say?
- Prostate cancer is the most commonly
diagnosed cancer amongst
men in the United States.
- Very important to point out.
While it's the most common cancer,
it's also the cancer
that many men die with.
Not of.
So like there's a huge majority
of men over the age of 80,
who actually have prostate cancer
but end up dying of other causes.
So what we've come to realize
and how we've changed our management
with prostate cancer is
unless it's an aggressive form
of prostate cancer or a treatable
form of prostate cancer,
we do a watchful waiting period
where we monitor but don't actually treat
because what we've come
to realize is treatment
and even diagnosis in
some cases can be worse
than just letting the disease be.
- It rarely occurs in men under 50.
- Oh, I don't actively think
about being susceptible to cancer.
It's not in my family.
I'm a young person who
can take on the world.
- Testicular cancer is a cancer
that the Try Guys need to worry about.
- Okay.
That was a weird scene.
And I don't know if they
did that for comedy.
A doctor should never be palpating an area
without visualizing it.
Yes, you might be able to feel masses,
but you might miss like a terrible rash.
You might press on an
area that's very tender.
- Because testicular cancer
is the most common cancer
amongst men, age 20 to 40.
- That's true.
And actually testicular
cancer has this like
weird bimodal distribution where it peaks
in younger men, kind of flattens out
and then also peaks in older men as well.
The good part about it is it's rare.
The second good part about
it, it is quite treatable,
even if it spreads.
- So we're gonna do the genitourinary exam
and examine your testicles to see
if there's any abnormality, okay?
- We're not just checking the testicles.
We're checking the epididymis.
We're checking the glands.
We're checking for rashes.
We're checking the pubis.
We're checking the pubic hair.
- The left one feels just fine.
- Do I need to cough?
- You don't need to cough.
When people say to cough,
what we're actually looking at is hernias,
which are checked in the same area.
And the reason we cough
by the way is to raise
intraabdominal pressure
so that when we are in the inguinal canal
if there is a hernia
we'll feel it poke and
hit like the intestines
or abdominal content poke our finger
while we're in there.
- Man that are age 25 to 40
have to get their nuts felt
and men that are age 50 or older
have to get their butts poked.
- That's basically right.
- That's not basically right.
We actually have moved away.
The United States Preventive
Services Task Force states
that prostate exams are a
shared decision making process
between a doctor and a patient,
not something that is
unequivocally recommended.
- Lie on your side with
your right side down,
bring your knees up a bit
to expose your bottom.
Okay.
- Bottom exposed.
- Don't some people bend over?
- Yeah, that can be done also.
You can just stand up and lean over
and put your elbows on the table.
- Has anyone done like missionary style?
- The doctor had us lay our sides.
Eugene, of course bent
over because he's Eugene.
- I think it goes deeper
when you do doggy style.
- And he poured a ton
of lube on that finger.
- Actually, when we were med students,
we would do this, and I
remember the simulated patient
that would actually be
having it done to him
multiple times over and over again
would check our nails
and had a nail clipper
with him to actually decide
should someone clip their
nails before doing it?
Cause apparently people
have hurt him in the past.
- Pressed his finger up
against my delightful anus.
- Oh.
- Some pressure.
- And then just went like
"Blahgablow!"
He was in my butt.
- Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
- And then he said, okay, we're going.
And then, boom.
- And it's nice and smooth.
- Great.
- You're essentially checking for masses.
You're doing like a sweeping motion,
cause the prostate is
at the bottom portion.
If you feel any irregularities,
if you feel enlargements
those are all potential abnormalities.
- Everything feels fine, normal, smooth.
- So that was efficient.
Super quick.
Very painless.
Whoa, that was way deeper
than I expected.
Lubed up, in and out.
- And you feel fine, all right.
- Okay.
- And here's some tissue if you need it.
- I actually did a simulated prostate exam
on a robot in the UK on live television.
Here you go.
So we have to do something
called a digital rectal exam.
- It's a finger up the bum isn't it?
- It's a finger up the bum.
(audience cheering)
- What are we gonna be doing today?
- Well today we're gonna
be doing a little bit
of electric stim on our
gentlemen right here.
We're gonna use it to
simulate and mimic labor pain.
- Do you think we'll die?
- Once we can't handle any more pain
our safe word is epidural.
- Childbirth is so painful
that you would gladly
have a needle stuck
between the two vertebrae
in your back.
- It is a needle and then
usually a catheter is inserted
over it in order to give a
continuous line of medication.
And the purpose is not for anesthesia,
but for analgesia to
basically allow the patient
to not feel terrible pain but
to still keep some sensation
of their contractions, keep some ability
to contract and push.
- This will mimic a lot
because it'll actually
make the whole abdominal region contract.
- In real childbirth,
it's your full torso.
It's your stomach and it's your back
- And your uterus, so you
can put it inside you.
- You may not know this
but a great many woman
poop on the delivery table.
- Because the act of
pushing is very much like
having a bowel movement.
- That's very true.
And that happens quite often.
I think I said it like so many times
in my videos and people
still don't believe me.
(Ned screaming)
- Epidural, epidural, epidural.
- Ironically, I feel like
I've seen that happen
in the hospital where patients said
that they didn't want an epidural,
and then they changed their minds.
- My wife had an emergency C-section
with our first child.
So I'm behind a curtain
with my wife and the doctors
are doing their thing behind the curtain.
They said, wait until we
give you the cue to stand up.
I thought I heard the cue.
So I stood up.
- And I'm gonna predict
what he's gonna say.
He's gonna say that the
uterus is completely inverted
and laying just on the belly.
And he passes out.
- And I look and what I
saw was my wife's abdomen,
you know, cut open and clamped back
and on a table next to her.
They'd taken out her
intestines and her liver
all the sudden they were
in bowls on the counter.
- That's how they do C-sections.
- What?
They did not remove his wife's liver.
I promise, they did not remove his wife's
Maybe it was the placenta
or something, but
(television static)
- This is Travis.
This is one of Ned's best friends.
They went to high school together.
- So this is our high
fidelity birth simulator.
Her name's Fidelity?
Hi Fidelity.
- So it's time, let's do this.
- All right, honey, I
need you to push for me.
- And as we're pushing,
- Nine, eight.
- All right.
So this is going to be a lot
of pain and pressure for the mother.
- You're doing great.
You're doing great, Travis.
- Come on, push, do it.
- Oh, you're doing so good.
- A lot of times it's
nurses doing the coaching
a lot better than the
doctors, not gonna lie.
- What do you mean help him?
There's nothing to do, like pet it?
- Help spread the labia.
- So basically what you
want to do is you wanna
control the baby's head.
So it comes out very slowly and gradually
cause the last thing you want is for it
to come out real quick and
then actually cause a tear
in the vagina.
So you want to control it
and make sure it's coming out smoothly
and help the baby rotate out
so that there is no chance
of the shoulder essentially getting caught
and causing damage to the nerves
that supply the arm.
(Keith screaming)
- Oh God, it's insane.
- Baby's head coming out.
There we go.
- At that point, you wanna visualize
that the umbilical cord is not wrapping
around the baby's neck.
Cause otherwise you wanna
remove it right away
because it could actually choke the baby.
- She's like screaming now, right?
Like how do I kind of just
like diffuse the situation
like emotionally?
- Get the baby out.
- Why are you tipping
it away from the table?
I want the table to catch the baby.
- In real life, you're gonna
have to catch the baby.
- I have to catch a baby?
Well, it doesn't shoot out.
- The last part does shoot out.
Cause remember there's a lot of force.
And then once like the major
areas like the shoulders
and the hips are out, then the
baby's kind of very slippery.
So you want to be able to get
a good grasp grabbing almost
like by the back of the neck
gives you a better support
on the top, and then the
second hand is on the bottom.
- Gently push down and
then gently pull up.
- So down.
- So when you push down, you
actually drop the shoulder
below and then you get the
other shoulder up as well.
- Well, baby.
Oh, there we go.
- No, that was a little too hard, sorry.
- Widest part of the baby's out.
There you go.
Look at that.
- Whoa.
- You caught it, see look.
- Don't catch it.
- There you go, perfect.
- Here we go.
- And right away we do
something called baby
to breast where we bring the baby,
once we make sure that the
baby's Apgar scores are okay,
we bring the baby to the
mom, put it on mom's chest,
allow the mom to spend some
time with it, bond right away.
We see better outcomes like that.
Less stress for the baby as well.
Also during the process,
you always wanna keep an eye
on the dad that the dad
just, or the partner,
just like boom.
- The Try Guys aren't
the only ones who try.
I tried out some of the most crazy
and some good Kickstarter products.
Click here to check that out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
There was one that made me gag.
Click here to check it.
Come on, watch it.